bonsoir pour la salle ailleurs merci de
répondre à nos questions sur rt france
44% de la population israélienne
vaccinés ou en tous les cas qui a reçu
une première injection comment est ce
que la population accueille cette
campagne vaccinale
parce que on voit qu'il ya des
réticences en france un dernier sondage
qui date de début février 41 % de la
population française soit se faire
vacciner
déjà 44 % de la population donc israël
viennent vacciner les israéliens adhère
c'est le départ de la campagne indécent
deux cent mille personnes et les
vaccinés par jour aujourd'hui le la
rapidité de la vaccination ralenti dans
moins de la moitié de ce nombre est
vacciné par jour
donc les personnes qui souhaitent être
vaccinés ont déjà été vaccinées et le
gouvernement doit maintenant traiter
avec les parties de la société qui sont
plus réticentes
c'est pourquoi le rythme a beaucoup
ralenti
cela inclut des membres des communautés
dont il est arabe ainsi que des
communauté ultra-orthodoxe ultra
religieuses beaucoup de jeunes gens
refusent également de se faire vacciner
car ils ne considèrent pas être
particulier vénérable donc ce sont des
défis pour le gouvernement le
gouvernement d'en délivrer un basp
inverse qui sera reçu par les gens ayant
reçu les deux doses de vaccin et astor
on ne pourra pas avoir accès aux trajets
internationaux
on ne pourra pas se rendre et
supermarchés dans les gymnases
donc c'est une forme de pression du
gouvernement
afin de pousser les gens à se faire
vacciner et le gouvernement facilite
également la vaccination
aujourd'hui par exemple la mea sharim
une communauté ultra orthodoxe de
jérusalem un nombre de centres de
vaccination mobiles ont testé à mener
jusqu'au centre de la communauté
ainsi les gens peuvent se faire vacciner
sur leurs soldes sur le seuil de leur
porte des sultans à retenir sont été
vaccinées aujourd'hui car il était si
aisé de se faire vacciner
il ya également des pressions de la part
du premier ministre benjamin netanyahu
qui a dit qu 1,2 million de personnes de
plus de 50 n'avaient pas été vaccinés et
que si ces gens se faisait d'actionner
alors on pourrait sortir du confinement
rapidement donc ce sont des moyens de
pression au niveau du gouvernement
il soutient également un projet de loi
qui publierait les listes de personnes
vaccinées pour les autorités ces
autorités auraient ensuite la tâche de
les encourager à se faire vacciner
donc le rythme baisse et le gouvernement
fait pression pour que les personnes qui
ne sont pas encore certains ou qui sont
contre la vaccination se fasse vacciner
pollet slayer vous avez évoqué le pass
or vers ce fameux passeport vaccinale
c'est donc la prochaine étape dans quel
état d'esprit est encore là la
population face à ça parce que ça fait
débat en europe 1 même si certains pays
comme le danemark la grèce ou encore
chypre ont décidé de l'adopter
la plupart des israéliens soutient
l'idée d'un paquebot revers avec des
gens de toute la société et la plupart
de mes interlocuteurs pensé qu'il serait
juste que les gens aient le choix le
choix en israël
c'est de devenir un passeport vert
indiquant qu'on a été vaccinée ils ne
seraient pas vaccinés mais on peut
obtenir un geste gratuit qui est valable
pour 48 heures donc cela signifie que
son maxi nation il faut se faire tester
une fois tous les deux jours
c'est une option pour ceux qui sont
contre la vaccination bien sûr c'est
beaucoup moins facile que d'obtenir ce
parcours vert qui permet de se rendre
dans l'espace public
je souhaite cependant mentionné que le
gouvernement s'était livrera ses vaccins
vers une semaine après la seconde dose
et une ligne sur ce passeport explique
qu'il est valable que pour un six mois
cela montre que les parce que le
gouvernement n'est pas certain que
monsieur de vaccination que ces deux
vaccins resteront efficace à terme sur
tous ces vaccins venant de pfizer
[Musique]
de plus en plus tôt personnes dont au
moins nous avons le choix nous avons
cette option ne sommes pas obligés
d'être vaccinés si l'on compare cela
avec le sentiment en europe il est
certain que le niveau du soutien bien
plus élevée en israël que par exemple
dans plusieurs états européens player
vous venez de souligner le fait que
peut-être il faudra se faire re bac
signer plus tard c'est ce que londres
également a indiqué du coup dans quel
état d'esprit est la communauté
scientifique par rapport à cette
campagne de vaccination face aux
variants notamment qu'en pense la
communauté scientifique israélienne le
corps hospitalier et l'abattage 10
serait là c'est un échange ne perd que
la réception de stocks importants de
vaccins de pfizer aux entreprises
pharmaceutiques les informations tous
les sens et cela soulève des questions
de vie privée mais à part mais hormis
cela signifie que des vaccins notamment
le vaccin sont toujours incertains
efficace contre le variant britannique
c'est les variants dominants ont le plus
dominant est pour le moment en israël il
ya des inquiétudes concernant les
variants et sud africain et brésilien le
cours des deux jours il ya trois cas en
israël 2 cas personne qui a reçu les
deux doses du vaccin ont été tous
contaminés par les sud africains
donc il restait tout son concernant
l'efficacité du vaccin de pfizer contre
les variantes sud africain de
l'industrie médicale
israël est également inquiète concernant
invariants israélien qui pourrait être
résistant aux vaccins le problème c'est
que au fur et à mesure que les vaccins
sont dispensés jeu
virus évolue afin de casser outre ces
vaccins d'après les docteurs il est trop
tôt pour se prononcer les on pourrait se
retrouver dans une situation il faudrait
recevoir chaque année un vaccin contre
le cornac et russe tout comme on reçoit
chaque année un vaccin contre la grippe
les experts surveillent la situation et
c'est pourquoi le confinement est
toujours en oeuvre en exercice en israël
le premier ministre a déclaré que grâce
au passeport vers les personnes
personnes et pourrait se rendre dans les
cinémas dès la rechute vers ou des
bibliothèques et pour la majorité des
gens qui n'ont pas reçu des doses de la
vaccination
les doses du vaccin ce confinement on
n'aura aucun effet et le véritable
conflit pourrait durer encore deux
semaines
cela dépend du taux d'efficacité du
vaccin notamment contre l'église variant
sud africain et brésilien
merci pour la cia d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous jette que
vous êtes journaliste pour rt
internationale